after nearly 18 year fight for their
full benefits 911 first responders and
survivors will finally receive permanent
funding senators passed the Victims
Compensation Fund built ninety seven to
two yesterday in a bipartisan vote chip
Reid is on Capitol Hill with more on
this story chip for many this seemed
like a no-brainer so what took so long
well I'll tell you it is not often that
this sharply divided Congress passes
important legislation with an
overwhelming bipartisan vote but with
the lives of 9/11 heroes on the line
that's exactly what they did without
this bill the compensation fund was
expected to stop accepting claims by the
end of next year there's been the honor
in my life to work with the men and
women behind me Jon Stewart has
passionately championed the cause for
years and when he scolded lawmakers last
month they did their jobs with courage
grace tenacity humility 18 years later
to yours
they took notice the yeas are 97 the
nays are two the bill is passed the
Senate Tuesday joins the House and
overwhelmingly passing legislation to
aid first responders who became ill
while searching for victims and remains
in the aftermath of the 9/11 attacks
just a little bit of Solace the moment
is bittersweet
you lost 343 firefighters on 9/11 and
how many have you now lost post 9/11 we
just lost our 200th a couple of days ago
200th he'll be buried tomorrow I would
never imagine that
eighteen years later that we would be
burying 200 of our own and that toll
continues to climb as we speak today
Senate Republican leader Mitch McConnell
has been slow to bring the bill to a
vote in the Senate we've always dealt
with that in the past in a compassionate
way and I assume we will him again but
but after meeting with first responders
weeks ago and promising to bring the
bill to a vote
McConnell delivered on Tuesday first
responder John field who has spent 15
years pushing for this bill said he
wished they hadn't lost so many along
the way I'm gonna ask my team now to put
down your swords and pick up your rakes
and go home and hopefully we don't have
to come back Republican senators Rand
Paul of Kentucky and Mike Lee of Utah
are the only two who voted against it
and take a look at this photograph Jon
Stewart beaming as senator Mitch
McConnell walked by on his way to the
Senate floor now President Trump is
expected to sign the bill Friday while
surrounded by 911 first responders Vlad
chip thank you very much it's
interesting to note that Rand Paul did
tweet about this he says he supports our
heroic first response a pretty can't in
good conscience vote for this
legislation he says spending is out of
control
a lot of people take issue with that a
lot of people you're right do not
understand that reasoning at all